The following tape diagram
describes the relationship
between the amount of red paint
and the amount of blue paint
needed in order to make
Plummy Purple paint mix.
So they show us here that
for every 4 parts red,
you need 3 parts blue.
Or you could say that the
ratio of red to blue is 4 to 3
or that the ratio of
blue to red is 3 to 4.
Now, they tell us, suppose
the x-axis represents
the number of red paint
cans and the y-axis
represents the number
of blue paint cans.
So let's scroll
down a little bit.
So the x-axis is
the number of red.
The y-axis is the
number of blue.
First, find two sets
of corresponding values
of x and y and graph them.
Then determine whether the
relationship is proportional.
So we know if we have 4 parts
red, we need 3 parts blue.
So let me graph that.
So if we have 4 parts
red-- that's that axis--
we're going to
have 3 parts blue.
And what if we had 8 parts red?
If we had 8 parts red, well,
that's 2 groups of four.
Then we're going to need 2
groups of 3 for the blue.
Once again, the ratio of
blue to red is always 3 to 4.
Here, literally, you
have 3 blues and 4 reds.
So you have a 3 to 4 ratio.
Here, you have 6 parts
blue, 8 parts red.
The ratio of 6 to 8
is the same as 3 to 4.
Now, the question is,
is this proportional?
So you have a
proportional relationship
if the ratio between these two
variables is always the same.
And we already said,
the ratio between them
is always the same.
The ratio of blue to red is
always going to be 3 to 4.
Another sign that this is
a proportional relationship
is that it's a line.
And not only is it
a line, but it's
a line that goes
through the origin.
And that makes sense.
If I have 0 red, well, I'm
going to have 3/4 of that blue.
Well, 3/4 times 0 is
still going to be 0.
So this is a proportional
relationship.
We could check our answer.
Yes, it is.
And let me explain
that last point
in a little bit more detail.
So as we said, the
ratio-- and I'm
going to do this in the
right colors-- of blue
to-- I don't have an exact red.
I'll do this orange.
That's close enough.
The ratio of blue
to red is always
going to be equal to 3 to 4.
And so if you multiply both
sides by the number of red,
you could say that the
amount you have in blue
is always going to be 3/4 the
amount that you have in red.
You can also verify this.
When R is 4-- if you have
a 4 here-- 3/4 of 4 is 3.
Blue is 3.
And so if R is a 0, if this
is really proportional,
then this is also going to be 0.
A proportional relationship will
always go through the origin.
If you don't go
through the origin,
it's not a proportional
relationship.
If it's not linear, it's not
a proportional relationship.